let's talk about Alex Jones and Infowars
crackpot conspiracy theorist and
talk-show host Alex Jones said over the
weekend that he loves Trump so much that
he's ready to die for him I'll remind
you that this is someone who claims that
his conspiracy website Infowars will be
getting a seat in the White House
pressroom if they want it under Trump
although the White House has in their
defense denied that they've offered a
seat in the press room to Infowars here
is Alex Jones making the completely
unhinged proclamation that he's ready to
die for Donald Trump Trump is so
fire-breathing it's already good so
energetic so cunning so real and he's
having results so amazing that it just
makes me be endeared to Trump I'm ready
to die for Trump and I'm already ready
to die for America it's the same feeling
I have for America because he is America
you're America right because I study
policy I'm a policy wonk and I know that
Trump and Bannen really know what our
had what's happening they're really
trying to cut taxes they're really
trying to get loans to small businesses
they're really trying to get us out of
carbon taxes and Obamacare and they're
doing it they're delivering and it's so
well thought out it's so good I studied
history I've covered politics for 25
years 21 on air and I've never seen
anything like this this is bigger than
1776 if Trump can deliver and then I see
all the news I've got articles today
haha there's tens of thousands of
bureaucrats that are gonna leak
everything you're doing militarily and
sabotage you that's called treason
that's executional I agree with Alex
Jones on one thing which is I've also
never seen anything like this going on
in American government but my view on it
is a little bit different does anybody
else find it weird that Alex Jones
subscribes in parrots all these
conspiracy theories about government
paranoia and corruption the Illuminati
but then he's praising arguably the most
authoritarian big government billionaire
who's ever been in the White House it's
sort of a conflict isn't it my theory is
that he's going to have to turn on Trump
at some point I mean you can only prop
up pizza gate and conspiracy theories
against the media for so long
he'll make a 180-degree turn on Trump
eventually I'm increasingly convinced
this as a character and Curtin Mo who
formerly worked for Infowars said that
basically Alex Jones has figured out
that this entire new pro Trump thing is
profitable because remember Trump Jones
rather believes 9/11 was an inside job
said the government controls the weather
and creates tornadoes he said the
government's using chemicals to turn
people gay so so I am increasingly
convinced Rachel that this is just a
business decision for Jones it has to be
a business decision or I would severely
be worried about his mental state I've
told this story before and a lot of
people like it and some may not have
heard it so I'll tell it again I
personally believe that I sound like
Miss South Carolina I personally believe
that some people don't know Alex Jones
because they haven't met Alex Jones but
when I met Alex Jones at the talkers new
media seminar a few years ago he gave a
speech and the speech was mostly about
sort of like online video and it was
like a very technical speech it wasn't
about politics and he threw in just a
few little conspiracy type things but if
you had heard him speak you'd be like oh
this is just a media executive talking
about profit and loss and then
afterwards I was in a really small group
of people it was me with Alex Jones and
then the two guys from free talk live
which is like a libertarian-leaning show
produced in New Hampshire a mark edge
and Ian Freeman and we were just
chatting and Mark and Ian knew Alex
Jones I was just sort of like the guy
that sidled up without knowing anybody
just to listen to what the big boys were
talking about and Alex Jones said
something he was first of all he was not
talking like I've ever seen him talk on
any clip he was just talking like a
normal guy like you and I are talking
right now and he said something like how
do you guys think that went
I thought about really freaking him out
but I decided not to sort of saying like
he could have turned on the conspiracy
voice and the conspiracy talk but that
he chose not to and the entire context
and conversation I observed was of an
Alex Jones that is probably non-existent
to anybody who's only watched his videos
so that's why I think it's all fake I
think sometimes he intentionally comes
out with these sound bites like 17 1776
will rise again or that they're trying
to make the frogs yay and this is just
the latest one so we've debunked it well
this is my opinion I mean again it's
possible that it's the opposite which is
the real guy is the conspiracy nut but
he knows how to put on a normal
character when he's in like a social
situation or something like that the
strange thing is that we have a
conspiracy theory going on Alex Jones
who comes up with so many conspiracy
theories of his own well I don't think
there's any conspiracy in other words I
think it's just a character like it
doesn't it wouldn't be a conspiracy that
just Alex Jones portrays himself in a
particular way on his Joe on his show
right I don't know I mean it's kind of
like the opposite angle that he claims
it to be so yeah I mean I guess I make
I'm making the assertion that his entire
public persona is fake but to call it a
conspiracy I think it's going a little
bit far